we've just seen the election of jeremy
corbyn to become the scone assuring
really surprising leader of the Labour
Party in Britain and I think that this
is to be seen as something more like the
occupy movement the kind of ins
Democratic insurgency has driven him an
outsider to become the leader of the
second largest party and the question
now for him is how will he respond will
he respond like a traditional political
leader organizing those who voted in
there or will he recognize that the
forces that have that have brought in
there a really one saying we don't want
the system the political system to go on
in the old way is it more like a kind of
the Occupy movement or the indignados in
Spain or the people that have pushed the
government of Syria into power in Greece
and then how will those forces but or
behind his election how will they grow
how will they learn how will they learn
how to become part of a political party
and will they reach out to the other
movements would you like them across
Europe up and in this country with
Bernie Sanders are saying we do not want
to have a political system which is in
the hands of the banks and which is in
the hands of the kind of corporate
oligarchs and plutocrats and we want to
be able to have what they call in Spain
real democracy now I a democracy for the
ninety-nine percent so this is the issue
which his election has suddenly thrown
up all of the official media and all of
the official politics if you like across
Europe and the European Union is trying
to sort of break this to say this is
irrelevant or ridiculous and a very
unwilling to see they being you know
their own their own nice way of running
things are disrupted but I think the
disruption is coming this is coming for
sure and we wanted to come in my view
from the Democratic Left rather than
from if you like the racist and
anti-democratic or populist right and
therefore we want to see how I can
row and grow well and this is not just
the question for the United Kingdom so
well very surprisingly he's a he's of
bubbled up within what his tradition
scene is a very conservative country we
need to see lots of support and
solidarity internationally if he is to
succeed and I hope that very much that
he will reach out to these new forces
and not find himself trapped and
confined in the undemocratic character
of Westminster politics to me as an
American and an observer of politics
globally the significance of korban is
primarily that he gives evidence for the
hollowing out of the center politically
not just in Great Britain but here here
we it takes different forms here because
our party system is so different as this
equivalent phenomenon has taken
different forms in Spain and Greece and
many other countries France in a
different way the the old order it does
not reward does not excite does not
engage the enthusiasm of young people
who are trembling on the edge of one
abyss or another and so there will be I
think they're already being a series of
pros in different countries for forms of
political expression which ring true
which ring serious for large numbers of
people who feel victimized and reduced
to passivity by normal politics so what
the particular fate of Corbin will be
who knows but the the anxieties about
the inadequacy of mainstream politics or
or a year I think to stay